the opening scene features a crime
enforcer named Lorenzo Vitali who is
driving towards his secluded Winery in
Sicily with his grandson once there he
asks his grandson to stay in the vehicle
while he cautiously Ventures inside to
his horror he discovers that many of his
henchmen have been brutally killed as he
walks into the basement he finds a
retired US Marine and Dia operative
named Robert mcau who is being held at
gunpoint by two of Lorenzo's bodyguards
the latter asks for the reason why he is
here to which Robert responds that
Lorenzo possesses something that he
shouldn't have after a brief exchange
Robert kills the rest of the henchmen as
well as Lorenzo and the way he does it
is nuts to he punches his gun through a
guy's face I don't think that's possible
as he walks out of the winery he notices
Lorenzo's grandson in the vehicle and
instructs the boy to stay put without
moving however as he walks up to his car
the boy shoots Robert in the back and
makes a Quick Escape despite the injury
Robert manages to board a ferry to go
back to the mainland later that night
while driving on the Amalfi Coast Robert
pulls over and slips into
unconsciousness due to the gunshot after
a while a local Carabiner named Gio
bonucci finds him in this state and
decides to help him he brings him to a
remote Coastal Italian town in alamon
where a doctor named Enzo treats him
upon regaining Consciousness Enzo
informs Robert that Gio saved him he
also inquires whether Gio rescued a good
or bad man but Robert doesn't know how
to respond when he attempts to return
home Enzo intervenes insisting that his
wound requires time to heal and offers
him a place to stay Enzo takes care of
Robert and after 3 days of treatment the
ladder begins to walk with the help of a
Cane one day he Ventures outside to
explore the town hiding himself from the
cops around the streets he eventually
ends up at a local cafe where he meets
an owner and waitress named Amina she
serves him their best coffee despite him
having ordered a tea you're goddamn
right shortly after Gio comes to the
cafe on his regular visit with his
daughter Gabby and meets Robert while
Amina entertains his daughter Gio hands
over Robert's car keys and clears that
he hasn't checked his bags yet Gio also
mentions that he has parked Robert's car
behind the station and can retrieve it
whenever he feels better in the next
scene Robert makes an anonymous call to
the CIA Financial operations group and
speaks to an agent named Emma Collins he
tips her off about the winery in Sicily
and how it has been connect connected to
the illegal drug trade disguised his
normal business transactions after
conveying this information he renders
the phone dysfunctional on the other
hand Emma relays the information with
other CIA operatives Roberts spends the
next few days wandering around the town
and eventually gets acquainted with the
locals there in the midst of this he
also learns about kamora an Italian
mafia gang who harasses and threatens
the town people over their earnings
demanding regular payments in other
words they're bad guys and and Robert is
a good guy that's all you really need to
know one day Robert notices a local
seafood vendor named Angelo getting
beaten up by a high-ranking Kamura
member named Marco quaranta before
leaving he threatens Angelo that he will
come back next week to collect the money
following this the gangsters head to a
large building where the leader of the
kamora who is also Marco's brother
Vincent quanta is trying to forcefully
Evacuate the premises it turns out that
kamora is working on their grand plan
commercializing the town by building new
hotels Resorts and casinos in one of the
building rooms an elderly man in a
wheelchair refuses to comply with the
gang as a result the gang members hang
the old man from the window leaving him
to die just in case you didn't know they
were the bad guys yet on the other hand
Robert Enzo share a pleasant dinner
conversation and Robert insists on
helping him with his daily errands the
following morning he goes to the market
on behalf of Enzo and visits Angelo's
shop the kind-hearted Angelo refuses to
accept payment for the groceries stating
that it's his honor that Enzo's friend
has come over to his shop for the first
time meanwhile Emma and other CIA
operatives acting on Robert's tip off
arrive at the winery to conduct their
investigation there they uncover
millions in cash along with bags full of
illegal narcotics hidden in a sto room
surprised that these activities were off
their radar Emma and her colleague Frank
Conroy decide to go into the depth of
the matter on a rainy day Enzo is
examining Robert's wound when the latter
asks him for the reason why he treated
him without involving any ambulance or
police in response Enzo reminds him of
his first question that he asked about
being a good or bad person and how he
had no answers to it he claims that his
silence was indeed the sign of a good
person the next evening Robert retrieves
his backpacks and prepares to leave the
town but he is stopped by the sound of a
bell just then he notices the town
people rushing towards Angelo's shop
prompting him to follow them it turns
out that Marco and his gang have burnt
down Angelo's shop due to his inability
to make payments despite this dominance
the town people can do nothing but watch
helplessly later Robert along with some
towns People Help Angelo to clean up the
mass meanwhile Gio reviews footage of
the firebombing and calls the Italian
Central police for an inquiry about a
van that was seen outside Angelo's shop
in the midst of this Robert is gradually
recovering becoming a part of the local
community and deepening his friend ship
with Amina Amina he also explores more
of the local Cuisine of alamon
eventually adapting to the town as a
result of all this the kamora
interfering and bringing their influence
into alante troubles him far more than
he had expected on one routine day
Robert is seen enjoying his coffee at a
Mina Cafe when he spots Emma secretly
trying to take his photo Robert then
confronts her suggesting that she
capture the photo from a better angle
Emma asks why and how he has such
precise information about the winery's
real business however he sticks to
giving her some vague answers also
advising her to delve into her remaining
work as she leaves she addresses him by
his name which surprises him later that
day Gio goes to pick up his daughter
from school during this time he receives
a call from an unknown number informing
him that Gabby's school was over a bit
earlier than the other kids concerned
Gio inquires to one of the teachers who
reveals that an officer had picked Gabby
up just a while back in a state of Panic
he rushes home only to find his wife and
daughter held captive by the kamora Gang
Marco then beats him up in front of his
family punishing him for interfering in
their operations the gang threatens to
take the life of his family if he
interferes again in the evening Robert
notices Gio leaving Enzo's office with
blood patches on his face curious he
asks about the matter and Enzo explains
that such incidents are common in many
towns due to the kamur according to Enzo
the issue is like cancer with no cure so
just like cancer the next day Robert
goes to the church where he meets Emma
one more time she confirms that Lorenzo
Vitali had been on interpol's most
wanted list for a decade and that his
operation was quite huge in itself
intrigued about why he chose her for the
anonymous tip Emma questions his
intentions however he diverts the
subject by stating that she should be
focusing on why Sicily was being
targeted for these smuggling activities
promising to find the answer soon Emma
says that she hopes to know the answer
to her original question in their next
meeting that evening Gio and his family
are having dinner at a restaurant when
Marco and his peers interrupt their
quality time Marco demands that Gio help
them set up a boat for their private
business purpose Robert who is also in
the same restaurant overhears their
conversation and requests that they
leave the family alone in response Marco
threatens him to stay away from matters
that don't concern him in a calm tone
Robert expresses his growing fondness
for this town and its people he then
urges Marco to take his business
elsewhere and warns him of the
consequences if he doesn't comply when
Marco still ignores the warning Robert
twists his shoulder and locks up his
hand making him scream he says I'm
pressing on your hibby tibble nerve the
pain is going to get real bad he then
orders Marco to leave his gun on the
table and exit the restaurant with his
men after a while the enraged Marco
plans to go back in with his henchmen
and kill Robert but before they can go
forward with their plan Robert drives a
van through two of his hen and starts
fighting them at one point Marco holds
him at knife point and threatens to take
his life regardless Robert retaliates by
twisting Marco's hand and drives the
knife through his neck ultimately
killing him and he didn't even have to
grab his hibble biy nerve the following
morning Frank contacts Emma from Rome to
let her know about the latest station
bombing it's revealed that the cash
found earlier in the winery was also
linked to a similar terrorist act this
makes Emma realize that the kamora is
directly funding terrorism by paying for
smuggling drugs into Sicily furthermore
she speculates that Naples serves as the
primary Transit point for drug transpo
and suspects the involvement of another
team in Naples determined to unravel the
entire chain she begins her
investigation by interviewing key
members of the kamora for this she also
requests partnership and access with the
head of Naples Police later on we see
the same police chief attending the
funeral of Marco at Vincent's Mansion
during this he informs Vincent about the
involvement of CIA officer Emma who is
investigating their illicit trades
Vincent who is mourning his brother's
death becomes enraged by the statement
and slices off the chief's hand he then
threatens the chief to focus on finding
out the person behind Marco's death
after this Vincent sends the police
chief to the hospital with his severed
hand preserved in an ice bucket
elsewhere Emma receives a call informing
her about the police chief's predicament
shortly after she also gets a call from
Robert who tells her about the koras
involved involvement in the drug cartel
closely tied to the earlier station
attack Robert's call inadvertently saves
Emma's life preventing her from falling
victim to Vincent's planned bomb attack
on her car in the aftermath Emma is
immediately rushed to the hospital for
Med assistance there she meets Frank and
alerts him about the kamora upon
learning everything Frank assures her
that he will handle the remaining
operation that evening Vincent takes Gio
and his family as hostages and threatens
to shoot them in front of the entire
town if his brother brother's murderer
doesn't show up when Vincent doesn't
receive any information he shoots Gio's
ear and threatens to end him with the
next shot just then Robert reveals
himself to Vincent and asks him to let
the captives go he claims that he's
ready to be taken away and tortured but
not in front of the town's people
however Vincent who is as arrogant as
his brother refuses asserting that the
locals must witness the consequences
against the kamora but before Vincent
can kill him the town people start
recording the ordeal causing the
gangsters to retreat the same night
Robert infiltrates Vincent's home and
stealthily kills his bodyguards one by
one Vincent who is asleep is startled by
a drop of blood on his forehead the
glass right above him suddenly shatters
but he narrowly manages to escape he
then grabs his gun and tries to contact
his already deceased gang members
shortly after Robert approaches him and
forces him to take a lethal dose of his
own drugs Vincent tries to run away from
his Mansion but Robert follows him
eventually the gangster collapses on the
cobbled road of Naples and ultimately
succumbs to drug overdose the next
morning Robert pays a visit to Emma at
the hospital who expresses her gratitude
for saving her life he drops a bag of
cash on the floor and shares the story
of a man named Greg Dyer who had lost
his pension in a Cyber attack this makes
her realize that Robert had followed the
trail of the attack to the winery killed
Lorenzo and his henchmen and retrieved
the exact cash that was owed to Greg
curious she asks if Robert and Dyer are
friends to which he clarifies that they
have only met once in the next scene
Emma goes to Boston in order to deliver
the lifetime earnings to Greg and his
wife Greg asks about the identity of the
generous benefactor and wonders why
someone would go to such lengths for a
stranger however Emma replies that she
would love to know the reason as well
after she departs Greg happily asks his
wife to unpack everything because they
don't have to sacrifice their house
anymore one day at the CIA headquarters
in Langley Virginia Frank hands Emma a
package containing a diary and a note
from Robert much to her surprise it's
her mother's diary as she connects the
dots she learns that Robert is none
other than a friend of her parents from
the CIA in the final scene the residents
of alamon are seen celebrating their
victory in a football match Robert also
participates in the celebration with
some borderline cringe but still badass
dance moves as one of the locals
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching